hola muy buenas tardes am esta es una
decisión profundamente
decepcionante y peligrosa que elimina
eliminar la herramienta más eficaz de la
agencia de protección ambiental para
reducir la dañina contaminación
climática de las existentes plantas
térmicas carboneras y de gas
esta decisión otorga a los ejecutivos
carboneros y a los políticos de extrema
derecha exactamente lo que han estado
pidiendo durante décadas frustrar los
esfuerzos de la epea para establecer
sólidos estándares de contaminación que
protejan a las familias del país sobre
todo a las comunidades menos
con menos recursos como puede ser la
comunidad latina por ejemplo y cuáles
serían las consecuencias directas en el
país tomando en cuenta esta medida
las consecuencias directas son que la
agencia de protección ambiental no se le
permitirá obligar el cierre o el porqué
de plantas plantas de carbón o plantas
de gas o que se sustituyan con plantas
de energía limpia renovable a lo que es
y esto es algo realmente fundamental
algo muy bien importante sobre todo para
la comunidad hispana de eeuu
los latinos sufrimos
desproporcionadamente no sólo la
contaminación que causa una larga lista
de enfermedades mortales sino también la
crisis climática que esta contaminación
de combustible estudio genera es por
ello que esta decisión es perdón en esta
decisión es especialmente tóxica para
las familias latinas del país encuesta
tras encuesta nos revela que la inmensa
mayoría de los votantes latinos reconoce
este gran peligro y así que el gobierno
federal actúe y nos protejan contra esta
contaminación la decisión que la muerte
acaba de anunciar entorpece grandemente
esta protección crucial que todos
necesitamos y ahora qué repercusiones
puede tener esta medida en el resto del
mundo teniendo en cuenta que es estados
unidos el segundo mayor emisor de co2
en estados el segundo el segundo mayor
emisor es el dolor pero históricamente
es el mayor de la historia
lo que lo que estamos viendo ahora mismo
es obviamente no sólo en
eeuu tiene que dar ejemplo de eeuu tiene
que ser un líder mundial en el combate
con el cambio climático no podemos
volver a los cuatro años previos a la
actual administración en la que nos
convertimos en un paria internacional
por habernos incluso hasta renunciado al
acuerdo de parís am
la ciencia nos advierte que se nos acaba
el tiempo para combatir la crisis
climática nadie debería hacerlo aún más
difícil para que el gobierno use las
herramientas efectivas para proteger a
las familias en las comunidades del país
como les indicaba antes la ciencia es
clara para 2030 tenemos que reducir en
un 45 por ciento las emisiones de
combustibles socios y para el año 2050
eliminarlas por completo lo que nos
estamos jugando aquí es ni más ni menos
en el futuro de la humanidad